have a look at what's going on this is
why I talked about x-squared right let's
just workshop the first question
together the function f of X equals x
plus 3 is defined over the domain 0 is
less than or equal to X is less than or
equal to 2 can you draw this with me
maybe you want to make a subheading
where you are going to start your
exercise let's just draw this and work
it through together we're going to draw
this very simple function in a
particular domain when we draw this
we'll be able to answer all of the all
the questions that are there but it'll
be much easier to actually see them so
when you draw this guy X plus 3 is that
gonna be enough my axes we'll find out
in a second what is X plus 3 look like
you can visualize the entirety of X plus
3 probably here it is there's X plus 3
it's got our gradient of 1 and it's
visually you know it's been shifted up
vertically 3 units okay
I'm not going to draw this yet though
because I don't want all of it there's a
restriction on it from not to to which
part of this line am I going to draw hmm
where's it going to start from it's
going to start from war which axes are
going to start from because I'm going
from here thinking vertically in terms
of you know where I am my restriction
starts from here there's x equals 0
because that's a horizontal thing and it
keeps on going keeps on going until it
hits 2 and then it stops that's it
that's the whole thing ok so I'm going
to draw some indicators there do you
have to put those on big fat dots on the
ends you don't have to but we have
language to describe whether I actually
exist at those points or whether I don't
and I actually know whether I exist or
not why am i doing field circles
have a look what part in the question
tells me I need filled circles here
rather than hollow ones say that again
surely nice and loud the inequality says
it's equal to zero it's equal to two the
boundaries are included okay that's what
my filled circles are for very good so
now I'm going to state the range of X
that's sorry the range of f of X that's
the initial question so for Part A the
range is talking about where I am up and
down yeah up and down what's the lowest
spot here
what's that value that's three yeah I'm
thinking about range yeah and then I go
up I climb up a little bit to here
what's the gradient slide again it's one
so every time I go across the unit I go
upper unit across the unit upper unit
that means if you're going across two
you're going to go up 2 as well is that
okay so therefore I can say the range of
f of X range will be 0 is less than or
equal to Y sorry what'd I just say 0 3
is less than or equal to 0 Y is less
than or equal to 5
okay with that now I usually state range
in terms of X's and Y's right this is
why I can also say because y equals f of
X I could just as easily say that 3 is
less than or equal to f of X which is
less than or equal to 5 is that okay
these the two things are identical to
each other
what's Part B asking state the domain
and range of F inverse
what did we say when we looked at the
big table and we drew everything about
algebraically the difference between a
function and its inverse what did we do
with the variables we swapped their
places right we switched them around so
everywhere we saw an X we put a wire
everywhere so while we put an X okay
so therefore see this range here which
has wires in it when you do the switch
what will it become when you switch
around this Y and you put an X in there
it's not talk about range anymore is it
it's talking about domain so therefore I
can say the domain of the inverse is 3
it's less than or equal to X is less
than or equal to 5
yeah now I want to work out range where
do I get that from have a look you know
switch right
I want wise where did I see a
restriction on X yeah 0 a 2 back in the
original question right so that's my
range restriction for the universe zeros
there so you could why that's the liquid
- ok what would it look like where is
this thing going to be between 3 & 5
horizontally between 0 & 2 vertically do
do you see it do you need to turn your
page 45 degrees and then think about
where the line of symmetry is going to
me where's the line of symmetry y equals
x that's a terrible wife is X sorry
that's better where's the reflection key
see where it's gonna go just see where
it's going to land I think it's gonna
land here yeah do you see it see how
there's three and there's five do you
see the reflection across right do you
see how useful it is to think visually
about what's going on and that would be
- yeah and then you can tell you write
down the rule for F inverse of X so what
they want is an algebraic expression so
I have enough space over here what do I
do with those variables I'm gonna switch
them around right so instead of writing
Y or f of X rather
equals x plus 3 what are the two things
I switch well the inverse will look like
this
here's the X on the left hand side I
want and on the right hand side I have F
inverse see that's like the Y right plus
3 that's a bit messy I should write this
more neatly I'll subtract 3 from both
sides and that gives me this just like
you saw before you happy with that okay
the hardest part about this is all of
the weird language surroundings you know
how that like really that's the answer
that's the most complicated object we're
going to deal with you it's not hard
stuff but the language around it is kind
of what does it even ask you okay